Every universe is different each one just
a fraction unique thus the infinity stones
are unique Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my full marvel what if episode 9 finale
video there's a whole bunch of easter eggs and
setup for what if season 2 so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything i will be doing videos
for hawkeye episodes that's going to be the next
marvel disney plus series that'll start really
soon careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the episode yet because we'll be talking about
everything we'll just start at the beginning and
go through shot by shot talking about easter eggs
moments starting with the episode title what if
the watcher broke his oath that's a reference to
the watcher's oath to not interfere in the affairs
of lesser beings he's talked about it in every
single episode the whole reason why the watcher
took this oath in the first place is he actually
took it as a sort of penance a long time ago in
the history of the watchers race they actually
did use their cosmic abilities to interfere with
the affairs of a planet to try and help them
but it wound up leading to the destruction of
that race of people the punishment they wound
up levying on themselves was to watch the universe
unfold watch time unfold and no longer interfering
but if you've ever read any marvel comics you
see that the watcher talks to the avengers all
the time we do have live action mcu watchers
that we've seen in guardians of the galaxy 2
stan lee's character is literally an agent of the
watchers so i think it's only a matter of time
before we see live action mcu characters actually
talking to a live-action version of uatu hopefully
they'll also find a way for jeffrey wright to
play that version of uwatu in the mcu as well
but the actual episode starts with a version of
the captain america winter soldier movie plot
with peggy carter's captain carter in the present
day of her universe she's got the same stealth
version of her suit just like captain america
did in the movie they're going after the same
ship in the movie being held hostage by batroc
the leaper who did come back from the movies to
play his character that was actually one of the
brand new movie actors that came back all the
other movie actors like chadwick boseman coming
back as t'challa star lord benedict cumberbatch
coming back as dark doctor strange they were
in previous episodes most of the characters in
this final episode were being played by the movie
versions of the characters with a few exceptions
this time though they have a couple twists on
the jokes at the beginning of the movie couple
of the references they make like this version of
black widow tries to set up captain carter with
bernard from accounting instead of the woman
lillian from accounting that she was trying to set
captain america up with she then mentions the name
steve talking about her version of steve rogers
and peggy jokingly acts like she's wounded to
her core like ouch that hurt this whole boarding
scene with her taking out all the guards plays
out exactly the same as it did during the movie
the episode is a little bit longer than normal
but it's still a relatively short episode so
they kind of have to blow through some of these
plot moments instead of taking betroth down using
his own fighting style the watcher stops their
fight short to recruit her then goes around to
all the different universes that we saw in the
different episodes to recruit the main characters
stopping next on t'challa's star-lord's earth
who's in the middle of saving his version of peter
quill from ego the living planet with his version
of the guardians of the galaxy and the ravagers so
you kind of see that in each of the episodes when
he goes around recruiting people and then even at
the end of the episode when he sends them all back
they kind of tell you what happened after the end
of each of the different episodes because all the
episodes kind of ended on wtf cliffhangers like
uh r.i.p this universe most of the characters got
happy endings even though they didn't save every
single universe then this is actually really cool
this whole gamora iron man scene this is actually
a look at the missing episode with iron man and
gamora where they got sent to sakaar instead of
the hulk and thor if you didn't see my earlier
video where i explained what happened to this
episode there were supposed to be ten episodes
of what if season one the reason why there's only
nine is because they ran its delays because of
the virus with production issues so they implied
that one of the episodes got pushed to season two
so maybe they'll follow up with this version of
gamora and iron man during season two we'll see
so this version of gamora is wearing thanos armor
and has his giant double bladed sword this version
of iron man has a version of the hulk buster that
is created from the leftover trash on sakaar so
call it the trash buster armor they're currently
on nidavolir the dwarven home world where e tree
is in the middle of melting down their universe's
version of the infinity gauntlet them having
just destroyed their version of the infinity
stones iron man makes the exact same avengers
age of ultron reference wrapping the world in
a suit of armor the closest reference i could
make to that like a giant cosmic iron man armor
suit would be like the god killer armor which
is actually an iron man suit of armor that was
built by the dark celestials the aspirants maybe
they'll do that and what if that feels like a very
animated thing to do because i don't think we'll
ever see it in live action but in this quick scene
of them they basically recap the events of their
episode and then the watcher shows up to recruit
gamora and provide some more context for what
happened this gamora is still a hero she's still
a good character she hasn't gone bad she took
thanos armor from him when she defeated him with
iron man's help and when they took the infinity
gauntlet from him when iron man makes fun of the
watchers saying he's going to kick his moon-shaped
ugly face that's a reference to avengers infinity
war where peter quill was making fun of thanos
face calling him a purple space grimace with a
nut sack chin but basically this whole scene
is meant to be a very avengers infinity war
kind of scene like thor going to get stormbreaker
except they're going to get the infinity gauntlet
melted down because e tree made the infinity
gauntlet and even though they don't reveal it
till later it's also kind of implied that iron
man is the person who built the infinity crusher
device in this universe the device that they used
to atomize their version of the infinity stones
i didn't think it was kind of weird that they only
wanted gamora for the guardians of the multiverse
team like wouldn't you also want iron man it
feels like a pretty good person to add to the team
this iron man also has the distinction of being
the only iron man that they did not kill in an
episode then the watcher goes to killmonger black
panther's earth to recruit him and they show what
happened after the end of his episode pepper potts
and shuri having teamed up with adorama lager who
also learned the truth about what he did killing
both iron man and his version of t'challa so the
watcher coming to join him is actually kind of a
blessing in disguise offering him a way to escape
justice in his own universe and obviously based on
the ending of the episode he's not coming back to
this universe any time soon then he goes to party
thor's universe who's in the middle of fighting
all the sub ultron robots and they play it for
a funny moment with him just taking a hot second
to catch on to what's what he brings all the
characters to this special extra dimensional space
conjured by dark doctor strange to make them feel
more comfortable but the space where they are is
kind of like a pocket dimension outside the normal
multiverse that's also meant to be foreshadowing
for the big twist at the end too with the version
of killmonger in the version of arnhem zola
ultron they get trapped in yet another pocket
dimension but doctor strange explains that he
built it to look like this from captain carter's
memories just to make everyone feel a little
more at home making it look like the english pub
where she and steve rogers had their final drink
together before that last mission in episode 1.
this is also meant to foreshadow the mid-credits
scene of the winter soldier version of the hydra
stomper steve rogers he gives party thor another
one of those never-ending magical beers like he
did during the doctor strange post-credits scene
and in thor ragnarok and if you remember they also
had the neverending magical beers during the party
thor episode as well i love the little joke that
they gave chadwick boseman here too his t'challa
star-lord makes fun of the watcher when he shows
up again out of nowhere like come on man get a
new trick they said of the whole killmonger black
panther subplot with him clocking the ultron robot
heads starting to get the idea about the infinity
stones and when the watchers explaining everything
to them he mentions eternity the living embodiment
of the multiverse he says that he was searching
all of eternity for one true hero but then got the
better idea to pull the best from each universe or
the ones that he felt like were necessary because
let's be honest if the multiverse is supposed to
be theoretically infinite if he pulled the best
hero from every universe there would be like a
billion people on this team and then he gives them
the actual guardians of the multiverse team name
so the idea is that even though the roster of
the guardians of the multiverse team will change
season to season the team itself will continue
throughout the series however many seasons it runs
doctor strange and the watcher give them all
the same powerpoint presentation that they gave
iron man at the beginning of avengers infinity
war about the history of the infinity stones
we'll also get a little bit of this backstory more
context during the eternals movie as well because
they'll be telling the cosmic origin of the mcu in
a way that they did not do during the loki series
they have the funny moment with the multiverse
chinese delivery because party thor gets super
hungry so you just see them all eating chinese
that doctor strange brings them from across
the multiverse the multiverse's finest chinese
restaurant gamora explains her infinity crusher
device even though it winds up not working later
in the episode there's a lot of logic issues that
they run into i'll address that when we get to
that part of the episode but they basically imply
that iron man built this device in their universe
and they used it to atomize their version of the
infinity stones because you can't destroy
the infinity stones but you can reduce them
to practically nothingness they travel to another
version of earth in a universe where there's not
enough intelligent life to be a target of interest
for ultron until they start attracting attention
for themselves just giving them time to prepare
for their fight when doctor strange tries to do
that really awkward funny toast and he says
another wise sorcerer told him this lesson
he's just referring to himself like he is the wise
sorcerer that said this before then they actually
start their big fights against ultron who shows up
and each of the fights is kind of progressive like
getting more and more complex as they going on
with more and more combo moves of the multiverse
avengers working together that's really one of
the best things about avengers movies is seeing
different super powerful characters try to combine
their powers and do something different with them
when doctor strange gives them all their magical
armor power-ups saying it's non-compliant magic
what he means is they're dangerous spells that his
good half might not normally have tried you also
notice too that even though the armor is meant to
be invisible while it's still forming around them
each different suit bears characteristics from
each of the characters cultures like captain
carter's armor looks kind of like a medieval
british suit of armor because she's british
both killmonger and t'challa star lord's armor
looks kind of wakandan inspired party thor's
magical armor looks kind of asgardian inspired
i believe killmonger's line here see you on the
flip side is also a line that he quoted during the
black panther movie party thor references viva las
vegas which is a pretty common catch phrase trying
to soak ultron in lightning damage unsuccessfully
it's kind of like the first avengers movie when
thor tried to soak iron man with lightning damage
then they start to show off some of the really
cool avengers combo moves so dark doctor strange
creating many copies of thor's hammer to use
against ultron it'll be fun to see how they try
to do stuff like this during avengers 5 with all
the brand new characters that are coming together
we're actually gonna see some cool avengers combo
moves during spider-man no way home too because
spider-man is getting a bunch of new suits one of
his black suits for instance is going to be used
with doctor strange's magic so it's already kind
of like a combo move but the next big combo fight
move is doctor strange enhancing captain carter's
shield strike after which she grabs one of thor's
hammers and even though she would be worthy just
based on the logic here in party thor's universe
i don't think that his version of odin ever
put the worthiness enchantment on his hammer
so theoretically anybody should be able to wield
any of these hammers that are flying around here
but then next big combo is doctor strange causing
all the hammers to strike ultron simultaneously
in thor using his powers to cause them all to
discharge a huge combo lightning blast at the same
time like a plus ultra lightning blast t'challa's
star-lord stealing the soul stone from ultron
is a reference to the sticky fingers twist from
his episode episode 2 but it's also meant to
be a reference to iron man stealing the infinity
stones from thanos in avengers end game there was
also another reference to this when killmonger
joined all the infinity stones in the infinity
armor at the end of the episode too most of the
big wtf moments from this episode were either
avengers infinity war references or avengers end
game references with a few exceptions like all
the winter soldier references i was happy to see
that they brought the marvel zombies back with a
big twist doctor strange basically just uses them
to distract ultron long enough for them to portal
away back to ultron's original universe saying
that yes even though the zombies are really cool
the real reason why he brought them was because
he wanted zombie scarlet witch who was way more
powerful even though their fight was also way
shorter than i wanted it to be just another
casualty of a really short episode otherwise i
think this fight scene would have gone on for way
longer ultron basically shutting the fight down by
destroying this entire planet but the whole reason
for them going back to ultron's original universe
to fight him there was because of the arnhem zola
ai that they were going to use to disable him
and when they do step through the portal black
widow immediately winds up yoinking the soul stone
when captain carter tries to win her over form a
connection with her she mentions her da is alexi
that's a reference to alexi shastikov aka red
guardian david harper's character from black widow
and whose shield this version of black widow has
been using since episode 8. when captain carter
mentions the three people in the universe black
widow trust she's talking about herself or in this
universe it would be captain america steve rogers
nick fury and then hawkeye they have their own
version of a big hot potato scene with the soul
stone meant to be a callback to the avengers
endgame scene with iron man's nano infinity
gauntlet like hawkeye and everyone else running
around passing it from person to person trying to
play keep away from thanos i did love ultron
reacting to doctor strange eating his energy
blast that was going to level the planet like
he was going to blow this planet up again too
but doctor strange basically consumes all this
energy damage our next big combo team-up move is
black widow and captain carter using both of their
shields to tag team ultron after which the whole
team starts working together to tag team him and
this is obviously meant to be their version of the
avengers infinity war scene on the titan battle
against thanos then here's where we get a little
crazy with the way they use the infinity stones on
the series so ultron finally uses his time stone
to slow everything down but because dark doctor
strange still has his eye of agamotto in his time
stone he uses it to counter the effects so this
is where we start to get crazy with the logic
of how the infinity stones work which universe do
they work in and add to that later in the episode
when they claim that the infinity crusher device
won't work because all the infinity stones in each
universe are meant to be a little bit different on
the cosmic level so i feel like when it comes to a
lot of the logic with the infinity stones and how
they work in this episode there's a lot of hand
waving going on and it's a really short episode
so they're like okay we want to blow through this
plot so it's all about expediency it didn't take
me out of the story too much it didn't bother me
that much because the whole idea is that they're
not going to use this twist again during season 2
and they're not going to use this twist in the
live-action movies either but there's a very
important reason why you don't see a bunch
of different versions of infinity stones
being used against each other like you don't
want to have a situation with like 10 different
people with their own infinity gauntlets
all going at each other in a scene because
it would just completely break the story cue the
deadpool scene of him yelling about lazy writing
that's just lazy writing but then doctor strange
unleashes his true magical power on him and if you
want to make a berserk manga or anime reference
this would be like doctor strange's true apostle
form where he goes into like true monstrous
form then even though they're able to use the
infinity crusher to steal the infinity stones from
ultron's body like i said the way they explain it
per the logic of this episode it only works on
the infinity stones from its original universe
don't drive yourself crazy trying to make too
much sense of this then as ultron is kind of
laughing at them explaining the infinity stones
to them they have their version of the multiverse
avengers assemble moment one of the most iconic
marvel movie scenes of all time with them spinning
the camera around the whole team just like the
avengers movie then they finally bring back the
arnhem zola ai and use it to disable ultron long
enough for them to join the infinity stones back
with a big twist obviously because of what
killmonger is doing i did like their dueling
ai scene with the zola ai and ultron yelling at
each other inside his body there's a big easter
egg here too for arnhem zola's new body when
he talks about missing having a pair of legs
is a reference to him putting himself in a robot
body just like the classic comics that's what
party thor is referencing when he mentions the
stomach face and like that's literally right
out of the comics then obviously big wtf moment
killmonger uses his reprogrammed ultron head and
vibranium nanotech to basically do the exact same
thing iron man did in avengers endgame stealing
the infinity stones except it's more like stealing
the infinity armor which is also a big comic book
twist they pulled recently even though he kind
of goes off the rails he's not completely evil
like you're meant to understand his perspective
like oh i get it i get where he's coming from
killmonger's idea is to use these infinity stones
to restore each of the different versions of earth
in the different universes which is a very on
brand thing for killmonger to want to do but again
like i said this only gets more complicated with
the logic of how the infinity stones work who can
use them in alternate universes should they work
in alternate universes the way they dodge dealing
with this problem is by having that big pocket
dimension twist at the end another really cool
easter egg you probably noticed here too when
killmonger activates the power of the infinity
stones he gives off that giant burst of energy
this is a huge easter egg for dragon ball z dragon
ball super saiyan transformations if you didn't
realize that killmonger in the mcu was designed to
look like vegeta they talk about it a lot in the
behind the scenes on black panther that's why his
vest armor looks a lot like vegeta's armor also
killmonger's character in the black panther movie
in the mcu his backstory is meant to feel similar
to vegeta's backstory in the dragon ball anime
so if it wasn't totally clear here when they're
playing their cosmic tug of war with the infinity
stones this is actually arnomzola controlling
ultron vision's body trying to steal the stones
then doctor strange comes to that realization that
they were never meant to kill ultron they were
never supposed to they were just meant to contain
the problem they were never meant to completely
solve it they just needed to separate the infinity
stones from ultron's body so that's why he traps
them in the pocket dimension and because he's
still dead set on punishing himself for foobaring
his own universe dark doctor strange makes it
his penance to watch over this pocket dimension
for the rest of his life so it's just another
reference back to the watcher's mission like
it's his job to basically watch the multiverse
it is now dark doctor strange's job to watch the
pocket dimension also the funny thing here you may
have noticed is when they go back to his special
little base here that he created this pocket
dimension the infinity stones are now inside a
pocket dimension within a pocket dimension
like a russian nesting doll of dimensions
the watcher sends everybody back to their original
universes at the exact moment that they left
just claiming that they'll be the only ones who
remembered what happened during this adventure
there's a big easter egg for avengers end game
when captain carter asks him to send her back to
1942 to give her the same happy ending scene that
mcu captain america got when he went back to live
with his peggy carter they do wind up paying that
off with a huge winter soldier hydra stomper twist
though in present day this black widow's universe
has been completely destroyed so the watcher does
do her solid and send her to the other version
of earth where loki conquered the world during
episode 3. we also see what happened after the
end of that episode as well too they had just
activated captain marvel's pager and were about to
unthaw steve rogers captain america from the ice
so he's dropping her off mid fight where their
new avengers team and nick fury are battling
loki in their own version of the battle of new
york it's just happening on the shield helicarrier
after which she uses the mine stone to pacify
loki they imply that t'challa star-lord and his
version of peter quill eventually defeated ego the
living planet saving their universe so pretty much
everybody here gets a happy ending of sorts gamora
goes back to her version of iron man party thor
reunites with jane foster and then the watcher's
whole ending speech here is about him taking a new
different vow to not only continue watching the
multiverse but also on top of that now doing
everything in his power to actively protect it
then in the mid-credits scene captain carter lands
back mid-fight with batroc and is helped by her
original black widow who stuns him using her widow
sting and then they have this whole big winter
soldier reveal that the villains on the boat
had been after the hydra stomper armor and it's
implied that skinny boy steve rogers got a very
winter soldier-like story after the end of episode
1 where he survived a present day through science
like cryo-freezing in the hydro stomper armor
here you'll also notice is a much more advanced
much more modernized version of the armor than
the original hydro stomper armor from episode 1.
with all this tech all lit up around him and it's
inside this special containment cell like it's
literally a prison cell of a box kind of implying
that hydra at some point got their hands on him
and turned him into a mech version of the
winter soldier and maybe they'll just cover
that story during season two they did say that
captain carter will definitely be back in future
episodes so i feel like they probably should
have had one of those tag lines in the credits
where it reads thanos will return like at the end
of avengers infinity war like captain carter will
return i'll do a longer video for this mid credit
scene and more what if season 2 stuff tomorrow
but if you spotted any other big easter eggs
during the episode that i didn't talk about during
the video just write them below in the comments
all the hawkeye episodes are going to be starting
really soon i'll be doing videos for that make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss any of those and there was a brand new
eternals trailer video that just posted so i'll do
a video for that as well too everyone click here
for my new marvel daredevil returns announcement
breakdown and click here for that brand new house
of the dragon trailer in game of thrones easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!